Diversity and in any intellectual
organization,
I mean that's how good ideas arise.
They have to do battle with less good
ideas if to the extent that everybody is
accepting roughly the same paradigms for
inquiry and there are certain
expectations about what counts as good
results of your research.
That's not very good for diversity and
it's not very good for intellectual
ferment,
which is what you want to encourage.
I mean,
universities are set up to get people to
work together by having them disagree
with each other,
so what are the difficulties with the
relative homogeneity of opinion among
professors is I happened to be at the
same opinion as most professors.
Most professors are kind of Liberal
Democrats.
It's just that it discourages people
from getting into the profession,
which is very difficult to get into
anyway because they feel are there going
to be discriminated against or Sean or
just not included in the conversation?
I don't think that's necessarily would
be the case,
but it's discouraging to people
basically what you want in any
profession.
I would say the same thing if I were a
lawyer or a doctor is you want bright
undergraduates to look at your
profession as something they would be
interested in getting into if the
barriers to entry are really high and
there seems to be some requirement that
you tailor your views to fit the views
of your colleagues.
It's going to discourage people from
entering it and they'll go do something
else that's got a,
you know,
more reliable track to a career.
So I do worry a lot about the time it
takes for people to get a phd about the
difficulty of finding employment,
about the difficulty of getting tenure
and generally about the perception that
undergraduates have that this is a very
high risk career to get started.
I don't want people to feel that.
I want people to feel this is something
that we fund to do and doable.
Well,
I think,
I mean there are lots of ways in which
universities will never be a reflection
of the general opinion of the public and
they probably shouldn't be.
It's generally sort of sociologically
observed that the better educated people
are,
the more liberal they tend to be,
which would suggest that professors are
going to be more liberal than the
general public.
And I don't think that you want to see,
um,
universities in any way trying to have
any kind of quota system about political
views or views in general.
You want the market to work in the way
the market works.
Um,
but I think that one of the things that
would make it a little bit more likely
to get diversity into,
I would just say to oxygenate the system
that we're working in would be to make a
little easier to get a phd.
Um,
sometimes I think we should just give
more phds,
but even if we didn't get more phds,
if we just didn't,
if we didn't make it eight or nine or 10
years to get a Phd,
I think it would encourage people to
enter who would otherwise find lots of
reasons why it wasn't a very wise thing
to do.